excitement is building across the
country for Monday's very rare total
solar eclipse we're gonna bring you the
best views in a two-hour special reports
starting at 1:00 o'clock Eastern that's
noon Central time on Monday
chief weather caster Lonnie Quinn of our
New York station that's W CBS is here
with a very unique look on how it will
all go down Lonnie well good morning
everybody you know this is going to be a
heck of an event for us and to give you
a better idea of what exactly it is and
what you're going to experience where
you live we have set up this cool little
solar system right here in studio 57 now
we all know that the Earth revolves
around the Sun and that the moon
revolves around the earth but at least
twice a year they fall into alignment
and you get some kind of eclipse be it a
lunar eclipse or a solar eclipse the
total solar eclipse well that's the Big
Show and that's where the moon
completely blocks out the Sun and it's
only possible because even though the
Sun is 400 times larger than this little
moon the moon is 400 times closer to the
earth and as a result from our
perspective when we look up at the sky
the Sun and the moon they look like
they're about the same Scott same size
and when that Sun hits the moon and
casts its shadow on the earth you get a
couple of different types of shadows
number one most of you are going to see
a very large penumbra that's a partial
shadow where you still see a portion of
the Sun but a select few of you are
going to get to see the Umbra and that's
nature's big event that's where the moon
completely blocks out the Sun it's
called totality and the area where it
hits on the earth is known as the path
of totality and on Monday it goes from
Oregon to South Carolina
so Charleston South Carolina you are
going to get a bonafide 100% solar
eclipse if you go to say places like
Portland Oregon 99.5% and then if you go
away from this line be to the north to
the south you'll get a lower percentage
about 90% of the Sun is covered in
Seattle Denver Atlanta and then the
further away you go from that line the
percentages continue to go down 75% of
the Sun is covered in San Francisco and
Philadelphia and further away you go
from that the percentages continue to go
down but everybody in this country is
gonna see something on Monday so get out
there and check it out the big question
now becomes what's the weather going to
be like along that path of totality
and what we've done is we've put
together a map here showing you where we
believe the cloud cover is gonna be and
of course cloud cover is gonna make this
a problem it looks like the best viewing
is going to be around the Pacific
Northwest but as you make that push
towards say Nebraska it looks like
you're gonna have a pretty thick deck of
clouds and that's gonna make it tough to
view then as you go through the
Tennessee Valley thumbs up it looks
great there as you get to South Carolina
becomes an issue
not so much inland it looks like right
along the coast for I was just talking
about Charleston South Carolina
it looks like Charleston the forecast
for you now come Monday at totality
would be for quite a bit of cloud cover
even a rain chance so I put together a
list of who gets the best and who gets
the most challenging skies overhead to
view so what I've got for you at Madras
Oregon it looks great for you and
totality is gonna be anywhere from say
one to two and a half minutes 1019 to
1021 that's your local time in Madras
Oregon literally you will go from
daytime to nighttime you can see stars
in the sky it's gonna be great Sun
Valley Idaho good to go
Riverton Wyoming great Nashville
Tennessee Greenville South Carolina
again inland looking pretty good
however the difficult spots would be
places like Charleston South Carolina
where that cloud cover is going to be in
place Grand Island Nebraska st. Joseph
Missouri Columbia South Carolina as well
keep your eyes to the sky guys let's go
over to you now Jeff Lonnie thank you
very much we're not we're not in the
sweet few class we didn't know but we'll
still see something that's